i took a
quote from mate and i put it in a
newsletter the other day so i'm gonna
two of
both of our obsessions game theory
and um dating dynamics um so this was to
do with slut-shaming
uh female promiscuity has a tragedy of
the commons effect in the mating market
if one woman offers [ __ ] on the
second date it's harder for other women
to keep them in reserve until the fourth
date is their special treat this creates
a downward spiral of young women feeling
like they have to offer more sex and to
more guys just to stay in the mating
game thus [ __ ] shaming is a way of
enforcing a more restrained sexual norm
on other women so that not all women
have to become more promiscuous than any
one of them would like that [ __ ]
[ __ ] blew my mind
and
it's really unless you have this kind of
game theory perspective it's really hard
to understand why slut-shaming is mostly
done by women to other women correct it
also makes a lot of sense around why
women tend to be the enforcers of
slut-shaming because so frequently
because women are the ones who have an
incentive to protect the sexual
marketplace from becoming a price war of
easy sex
yeah
and this is also why you know the main
opponents of sex work are often married
women
right because they have the most to lose
a husband goes off you know and
spends money on an escort or some
financial dominatrix or whatever
and
if you just ask like okay where are
people's incentives you know what's the
incentive to impose a certain social
norm on
human sexuality often it's not that hard
to figure out why it's happening
there's another case i did a little bit
of research around who opposes abortions
mostly
and it's women
there are more women that oppose
abortions than there are men
and i think there it a lot of that might
be a a bit of a virtue signal right
because if you're
if you're a woman is like babies are
sacred
we have to protect babies it's kind of
like a way of saying my maternal
instincts are better than yours and i'm
going to be a good mom and one way i
demonstrate i will be a good and devoted
mom who who will you know protect your
babies
is
to insult other women who
seem not to protect
their fetuses i that's the first half of
it right that's what you guys put
forward in the book um and then i worked
it through using bro signs uh on my
newsletter
reading that first section about the
fact that women enforce it mostly and
why you can't have the price of sexual
access kind of get spiraled down and
down reading that got me thinking about
the equivalent for men and i think that
it explains simp shaming too
so i reword what you put at the top male
resource commitment has a tragedy of the
commons effect in the mating market if
one man offers gifts and resources by
the second date it's harder for the
other men to keep them in reserve until
the fourth date is their special treat
this creates a downward spiral of young
men feeling like they have to offer more
and more gifts and go on extreme
increasingly extravagant dates to more
and more women just to stay in the
mating game thus simp shaming is a way
of enforcing a more restrained resource
giving norm on other men so that not all
men have to become more resource
committed than any of them would like
similarly this explains why men are
mostly the enforcers of sym shaming
because men have an incentive to stop
sims from cheapening the value of all
men's resources it's hardly an iron law
men call women [ __ ] and men women call
men simps all the time but this game
theory explanation makes a lot of sense
to me if women give sex without
commitment it cheapens the value of sex
if men give resources or commitment
without sex it cheapens the value of
resources and commitment
yeah and you you can see this in some
weird little subcultures like financial
domination
right
where
you might not be familiar with this but
there's a certain kind of online sex
worker
who's just like
i'm the dominatrix
you send me money
men who fetishize supporting women
will just send these women like
thousands tens of thousands of dollars
and they they sometimes they drip feed
it back to them as an allowance and
stuff right
yeah and it
i don't really get it but like whatever
um
as long as you're a lot not like a
married guy and you're taking money out
of your your mortgage account and
sending it to some other random woman
but whenever other guys hear about
guys who are into being thin domed
financially dominated like that's like
the ultimate
simp and then the the teasing is like
relentless
um i think there's even a bit of um
stigma about you know men who visit sex
workers
for the same reason
it's like how much are you paying like
why can't you just go to
you know chris's club and pick up a
woman or
for free whatever
um
but i think this this is what you know
cultural norms are is our
it's often our attempts to kind of
control the mating dynamics of other
people why do you think it is that
men who work on
their charisma or their um abilities
with women in like a an over conscious
way
why do you think it is that there's a
bit of an ick factor sometimes around
that both from men and women
i think it's a funny thing i don't i
don't know how much of that is kind of
unique to
like this particular cultural moment in
like british and american
mating dynamics i don't know how much of
it is just
a sort of like
innate wariness of any guys who give off
cues of being kind of machiavellian or
sociopathic or narcissistic
right there's this concept of the dark
triad personality traits
psychopathy machiavellianism narcissism
and so the guys who are high on those
dark triad traits do tend to care a lot
about like
good body how they dress how they act
you know maximizing like cues of
dominance and status that they display
and kind of parlaying that into into
mating success
um
but
you know the guys who really benefit
from
like reading mate or reading manosphere
stuff are not typically those dark triad
guys
they're more often
guys who are kind of like
a little socially awkward and aspy like
me
or like i used to be and still am
where it's like i just don't understand
women i don't understand clothing how do
i get in shape
what is a conversation
like
doing kind of remedial
work on that i think is
you know that's a that's a huge win
because there's a lot of
guys out there with
amazing uh potential
that's not realized why because k-12
public education
doesn't teach any of this stuff
why would it
uh
male mentors like guys dads and uncles
don't seem to be bothering to teach it
well i think as well the the gap between
that generation and where we are now in
terms of what you need to know in order
to be effective in the mating market
this is one of the common criticisms
thrown around to some of the guys in the
manosphere that
bro you've been married for [ __ ] 40
years
like you you literally got into a
relationship during a different like a
prehistoric era
yeah
i think that is
like 50 accurate and 50
like a [ __ ] cope
because human nature doesn't change that
much yep i agree generation to
generation
it might be true that a lot of guys
dads and granddads and uncles
didn't actually have that much
like meeting experience themselves
right they might not have actually had
that many girlfriends they might have
only been in the mating market for like
two years before they married someone as
a college sophomore
right
um so they might not know what they're
talking about but on the other hand
uh
you know to the extent that they've had
real life experience and mating
experience
um
there's no expiration date on on human
wisdom
about
sexuality
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
oh